- Just look at her hands and my hands,
that's the difference here.
(drums)
- I've been making cakes for 8 years.
How is this a contest?
- Well, Bree has the techniques,
but does she have the creativity?
I don't think so.
- I am a professional cake decorator
and owner of Bree's Cakes
here in Los Angeles.
- I've maybe made like 3 cakes in my life.
I have been drawing my whole life.
I don't feel as confident I think.
At least the colors will be nice.
- I feel really confident about this
cause I do this everyday.
- Hi-five.
(squeals)
Let's do this.
- Alright.
- Wait, there are rules?
- What kind of rules?
- Okay.
That's necessary.
- That's doable.
- Okay.
(suspenseful music)
Oh.
- Oh.
Okay.
- Okay good.
So I decided for my Sweet Sixteen cake
to do very vibrant colors
cause if I was 16 again,
I'd want bright colors like
pink and purple and blue.
So I'm gonna take all those colors
and make a striped buttercream
and then top it with a fondant bow.
- So today I'm gonna be
making a cake inspired
by my favorite book, The Little Prince,
and I'm gonna make the
cake look like a meteor,
then I'm gonna make a little
rose made out of fondant.
It's gonna be great.
- It's not as easy as it looks, is it?
- Oh, no.
Awful.
Oh no.
Are you supposed to knead it like this?
- I don't know.
(laughs)
I've never used it before.
- This black goes with anything.
- There's gloves, your
hands are gonna get dyed.
- Oh, it's for art.
- You're like my competition right now,
I can't tell you everything.
- Oh. I'm not here to win,
I'm here to make friends.
(laughs)
- I am 100 percent self-taught
and I taught myself
how to make cakes from watching TV shows
like Cake Boss and Ace of Cakes.
I used YouTube a lot, just
kind of Googled things,
and here I am, 8 years later,
and now I own a bakery.
(upbeat music)
- So, I'm gonna do something really crazy.
- Uh oh. Are you gonna cut it?
- Yes.
I've never shaved a cake like this before.
And it's really hard.
- It's very risky of you to do that.
- Yeah, I'm a risk taker.
- You're a whisk taker.
- A whisk taker!
- You're welcome.
- The story of The Little Prince
is this little kid that lives
on a planet called Asteroid B-16,
and he falls in love with a rose
that grows on this planet.
- I'm gonna take a deep breath for her,
and say a quick little prayer.
(upbeat music)
- I'm really happy with it.
I'm happy that the colors
didn't bleed together,
and that the border
stayed structurally sound,
and the bow is standing
up without collapsing.
- This is Asteroid B-16, which is like,
16th birthday, so it makes sense.
It's thematic.
It was an accident, but it worked out.
It was a messy process,
you can see that on my
hands and the table.
I think it came together pretty well.
Now I guess strangers
are gonna come in and judge our cakes.
- Do we have to be here when they judge,
or can we like leave?
- You know guys, I didn't
have a Sweet Sixteen,
just cause I'm really bad at planning,
but I would've loved for
either of these to be my cake.
- This one definitely
sells the Sweet Sixteen,
something about the colors
and there's a bow on top,
so it's almost like a
present and a package.
This cake, I think, is
slightly cooler to me,
just cause it's weirder.
- Is this like a Beauty
and the Beast thing?
I don't really know.
- I think this one
represents the theme better.
- I am super impressed.
I do not know who to choose.
- This one, though, I have
to say is my favorite.
It's a rainbow, it just looks like
I want to put it in my mouth right now.
- If it were my Sweet Sixteen,
which I really wish it was,
I would take the weird one.
- For like a 16 year old girl,
I would think that this
is what she would want.
This is what I would want.
- I like this one.
- This is the cake I'd want to cut into
on camera in front of all my
friends on Instagram later.
(applause)
- Thank you, to the people.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
Well, what do I win?
Yay, look at my trophy.
It says, bragging rights.
- The Little Prince was kind
of an obscure reference,
and I kind of made it for myself,
like a selfish artist.
- Oh, this is going up
on a shelf in my bakery.
- Can we eat them now?
(upbeat music)